>> PREVIOUSLY ON "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL",
FROM THE THOUSANDS OF ASPIRING
MODELS WHO APPLIED,
35 ARE CHOSEN TO
BATTLE IT OUT
IN LOS ANGELES.
>> SOMEWHERE HERE IS AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
(cheers and applause)
>> WE MET THE HARD-WORKING
BRITA,
HOPING TO TAKE DOWN HER YOUNGER
COMPETITORS.
>> PEOPLE WILL TALK DOWN TO ME
BECAUSE I'M A WAITRESS.
THAT'S FINE. I'M TRYING
TO STRIVE FOR SOMETHING ELSE.
>> THE COLORFUL BRANDY...
>> MY FELLOW REDHEAD SISTA.
>> POWER TO THE PEOPLE.
>> MICHELLE, A WRESTLER WITH
SOME FIERCE MOVES.
AND TIFFANY...
SOMEBODY'S BACK.
>> HEY.
>> WHO LOST HER TEMPER LAST
TIME SHE TRIED OUT
FOR "TOP MODEL"...
>> THAT STANK...
POURED THE BEER ON MY WEAVE!
>> BUT CAME BACK WITH A NEW
ATTITUDE
THAT EARNED HER A SECOND
CHANCE.
TIFFANY.
>> (screaming)
>> ONLY 14 MADE THE FINAL CUT.
>> YES!
>> TONIGHT THEIR JOURNEY
BEGINS.
♪♪♪
>> I MADE IT. I'M HERE.
THIS IS JUST, LIKE, TOTALLY
TRIPPING ME OUT.
I'M GLAD TO BE HERE.
I DON'T PLAN ON LEAVING.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT I'D
MAKE IT THIS FAR.
AND TO, LIKE, BE HERE WITH
THESE GIRLS--
THEY'RE ALL SO TALL AND SO
BEAUTIFUL.
I'M NOT USED TO BEING ONE OF THE
BEAUTIFUL GIRLS.
>> HELLO!
>> HI!
>> SO CONGRATULATIONS!
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU GUYS MADE IT!
SO YOU GUYS ARE THE FINAL,
CHOSEN 14.
FORGET ABOUT THE SUBWAY.
FORGET ABOUT BROADWAY.
'CAUSE WHAT?
>> OH!
(laughing)
>> YOU GUYS ARE LIVING
IN LOS ANGELES.
>> WHOO!
>> I ASSUMED THAT WE WERE
GOING TO NEW YORK.
>> NOW THAT WE'RE
LIVING IN L .A.,
I THINK IT'LL BE AWESOME.
I THINK IT'LL BE
EXCITING.
>> SO LISTEN, LET ME TAKE
YOU
ON A LITTLE TOUR
OF THIS BACK LOT.
DO YOU WANT TO FOLLOW ME?
>> YEAH!
>> LET'S GO.
>> WOW.
>> YOU GUYS PUMPED?
YOU'RE PSYCHED?
>> BEING IN PARAMOUNT STUDIOS,
I FEEL LIKE A MOVIE STAR
RIGHT NOW, 'CAUSE THAT'S
WHERE MOVIE STARS GO.
>> HEY, GIRLS.
>> YES?
>> THEY'RE SHOOTING
A MOVIE.
>> (squealing)
>> GO, GO, GO, GO.
>> ACTION.
>> THIS IS WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
>> OH, GOSH.
>> FASHION POLICE!
>> FASHION POLICE.
>> (screaming)
>> WHERE ARE THE ALIENS?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT WHEN WE FIND THEM,
I'M GONNA
SHOOT THEM.
>> (laughing)
>> FABULOUS.
>> TODAY THIS IS YOUR FIRST
PHOTO SHOOT...
>> (screaming)
>> AND WE ARE GONNA TURN YOU
GIRLS INTO SEXY, HOT ALIENS
TAKING OVER MANHATTAN.
>> (cheering)
>> WE'VE GOT OUR VERY OWN PANEL
OF JUDGES WORKING WITH YOU,
ALL RIGHT?
SO WE'VE GOT THE TALL, SEXY AND
VERY ENGLISH NIGEL BARKER,
OUR PHOTOGRAPHER.
>> HI, LADIES.
>> WHOO!
>> AND OF COURSE, NOLE MARIN,
FASHION STYLIST.
>> WHOO!
>> AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST, THE
SUPER SEXY SUPER DIVA,
MISS...
>> JANICE DICKINSON!
>> BE AFRAID. BE VERY AFRAID.
>> SO I'M GONNA WALK YOU GUYS
BACK TO WHERE HAIR AND MAKEUP
IS WAITING FOR YOU RIGHT NOW.
ALL RIGHT?
>> ALL RIGHT! YEAH!
>> SO FOLLOW ME. LET'S GO.
>> MY MOUTH DROPS, BECAUSE IT'S
DAWNING ON ME
THAT THIS IS THE FIRST
COMPETITION.
>> ALL RIGHT, LADIES, THIS IS
DANILO.
HE IS A SUPERSTAR HAIRDRESSER,
OKAY?
AND MR. MATTHEW,
MAKEUP MASTER.
SO THESE ARE THE GUYS THAT ARE
GONNA TRANSFORM YOU
TODAY, ALL RIGHT?
>> YOU GUYS ARE BEING HANDED
THIS ON A SILVER PLATTER.
BE COURTEOUS, BE ON TIME AND
HAVE FUN WITH IT.
>> NOW YOU HAVE TO IMPRESS HER
AND JAY, BECAUSE SHE WILL
BE LOOKING AT YOU.
HOW OLD ARE YOU?
WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
>> BRITA.
>> HMM.
>> SHE'S OLDER THAN--
>> AGE IS A HUGE ISSUE FOR ME
FOR THIS BUSINESS.
I KNOW I LOOK YOUNGER.
>> 17. NO, 18.
>> WOW. WHAT'S YOUR
COLD CREAM AT NIGHT?
I LOVE IT.
>> AND PEOPLE QUIT AT MY AGE IF
YOU HAVEN'T MADE IT.
I HAVE NOT QUIT,
BECAUSE THIS IS
WHAT I WANT TO DO.
IT'S MY PASSION.
>> ALL RIGHT, GIRLS, LET'S TURN
IT OUT.
LET'S GET YOU IN
YOUR OUTFITS,
AND LET'S LET
THE MAGIC HAPPEN.
>> WHEW.
I AM PETRIFIED.
I HAD NO IDEA THAT IT WAS GONNA
START THAT FAST.
>> THAT'S A DANILO 'DOO
IF I EVER SAW ONE.
HOLD THAT FACE.
>> I THINK JANICE IS EXTREMELY
SCARY.
I WANT TO BE LIKE, "ARE YOU
GONNA MAKE ME CRY?
AND HOW MANY TIMES?"
>> ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
THIS LOOKS
DYNAMITE.
>> I'M ALWAYS NERVOUS.
>> OKAY. WELL, I
DON'T WANT YOU
TO BE NERVOUS.
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT THAT FIERCE
LITTLE WALK.
I WANT TO SEE
THAT MODEL COME OUT.
>> OKAY.
>> BOOM. LIKE THAT.
EXACTLY.
OPEN YOUR MOUTH
A LITTLE BIT.
CHANGE THE BODY UP.
RELAX YOUR LIPS.
>> LOOK HOW EDGY SHE IS. SHE
TOTALLY DOESN'T REALIZE
HOW GREAT SHE IS.
WE GOT HER ALREADY.
>> WHERE ARE YOU FROM?
>> I'M FROM MINNESOTA.
>> I WAS IN
REHAB THERE ONCE.
>> REALLY? HAZELDEN?
>> YEAH, I WAS IN ST. MARY'S.
>> OH, OKAY.
I DID A NICE STINT THERE BACK IN
THE '80s.
>> LEAN BACK A LITTLE BIT,
SWEETIE.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S A LITTLE MORE
LIKE, "UH ."
IT'S A LITTLE MORE...
>> REBECCA WAS A TROOPER.
SHE JUST GIVES OFF THAT SLIGHTLY
TWIGGYESQUE FEEL
ABOUT THE WAY SHE MOVED.
I WAS VERY IMPRESSED.
BRING YOUR BODY SO YOUR BUTT'S
HALF ON
AND HALF OFF.
THERE'S NOTHING COMFORTABLE
ABOUT FASHION.
EMOTE.
CHIN UP.
DON'T FORGET THE LIGHT.
YOU LOOK UNBELIEVABLE.
>> NIGEL, BEING OUR
PHOTOGRAPHER,
HE KNOWS WHAT HE LIKES.
AND IT MAKES ME FEEL LIKE,
"OKAY, I'M DOING
SOMETHING GOOD."
>> PUT YOUR SHOULDERS
MORE PROFILE.
THAT WAY.
>> YEAH, I THINK
THAT COULD WORK.
IT MADE ME LISP A
LITTLE BIT.
>> YOU'RE GONNA BE RIGHT UP ON
HERE, SWEETIE.
>> YOU KNOW,
IT'S SO HOT OUT THAT, LIKE,
MY KNEES GOT
REALLY SWEATY.
SO I KEPT FALLING
OFF THE CAR.
>> YES. THERE YOU GO.
>> AWESOME.
>> DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR ME--
BITCH JUDGE?
>> I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA BE
ONE OF MY FAVORITE JUDGES.
OOH! HELLO THERE.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> MICHELLE,
TELL NIGEL WHAT YOU DO.
>> OH. I WRESTLE.
>> YOU WRESTLE?
>> YES, I WRESTLE.
>> THERE'S THAT SORT OF-- AN
UNUSUAL SIDE TO MICHELLE.
SHE CAN GO QUITE
ANDROGYNOUS-LOOKING.
BEAUTIFUL.
CHIN UP FOR ME,
SWEETIE.
>> THIS IS MY FIRST PROFESSIONAL
PHOTO SHOOT.
I WAS JUST SITTING THERE, LIKE,
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
THEY MADE US WAIT, LIKE,
FOREVER.
I'M REALLY JUST TIRED
OF SITTING THERE.
THAT'S WHAT I AM.
>> MY STRATEGY IS TO
JUST HAVE CONFIDENCE.
I'M SURROUNDED BY
GORGEOUS GIRLS,
AND I'M ONE OF THEM,
SO, YOU KNOW?
>> YOU GO FOR IT?
TATIANA--SHE HAS A
LOT OF MOVES.
AND THAT'S THE KIND OF MODEL
THAT YOU FALL IN LOVE WITH--
NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL,
BUT BECAUSE THEY INSPIRE YOU
TO TAKE PICTURES OF THEM.
YOU'VE GOT IT, RIGHT?
>> GIVE ME SOME DIFFERENT
ANGLES.
>> SHE'S HOT.
>> I'M A TREKKIE.
I AM A TREKKIE,
AND I FELT LIKE ONE OF THE
ALIENS FROM "STAR TREK ."
>> YOU WORK IT OUT,
DAMN IT.
>> WE GOT
IT. YOU'RE DONE.
YOU DON'T NEED TO
WASTE ANY MORE.
OOH!
>> IT SHOCKED ME.
I WAS STILL
SITTING THERE.
HAVEN'T TOOK A PHOTO.
HAVEN'T TOOK
NOTHING.
>> YOU SLEEPY?
WHY ARE YOU SLEEPY?
>> BECAUSE Y'ALL ARE
TAKING LONG.
>> HONEY, WHEN
YOU'RE DOING
PARIS SHOWS AFTER PARIS SHOW,
YOU'LL BE MORE
TIRED THAN THIS.
BRANDY--SHE JUST HAD A REALLY
BAD ATTITUDE, YOU KNOW?
THIS IS OUR FIRST SHOOT OF THE
ENTIRE COMPETITION.
SHE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN UPBEAT.
SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN REALLY
EXCITED.
>> BRANDY, IS IT?
>> YES, SIR.
>> BRANDY NOT
FEELING IT RIGHT NOW.
>> WHY NOT?
>> UM,
'CAUSE I WAS WAITING
SO LONG.
I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
>> BECAUSE YOU HAD TO
WAIT SO LONG?
>> YEAH, AND I WAS
GETTING SLEEPY.
SO I'M IN THE MIDDLE OF
SLEEPINESS...
>> BRANDY, BRANDY,
BRANDY.
SHE CAME ON THE SET,
WAS IN A BIG MOOD.
WOULDN'T LOOK AT ME.
WOULDN'T SMILE.
WELL, YOU
KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S NOT
GONNA CUT IT.
RELAX THE HAND.
CHANGE IT UP.
CHIN UP.
DON'T FORGET
YOUR LIGHT.
THAT'S A WRAP.
>> ON A SCALE FROM
ONE TO TEN,
I GIVE MYSELF
AN 11,
'CAUSE I THINK I
DID REALLY GOOD.
>> NOELLE, WHAT ARE YOU THINKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW?
>> THAT I JUST DESTROYED
THIS BUILDING.
>> YOU LOOK
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE,
BUT THAT'S NOT ENOUGH IN THIS
BUSINESS.
>> OKAY.
>> DRAMATIC SHAPES.
THERE YOU GO.
FILL THAT FRAME.
>> GOT A 19-MONTH-OLD LITTLE
BOY WAITING FOR ME
AT HOME.
I WANT TO BE ABLE TO PROVE TO
HIM THAT JUST BECAUSE
I HAD YOU YOUNG DOESN'T MEAN
THAT I DIDN'T MAKE ANY
OF MY DREAMS COME TRUE.
>> CHIN UP FOR ME A TOUCH.
BOOM.
THAT'S WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
>> NOW YOU'RE GIVING
US ENERGY.
>> RIGHT THERE.
REMEMBER TO SUCK
IN THAT GUT.
>> THERE YOU GO.
WORK IT OUT.
>> OOH, I LOVE THAT.
>> DAMN. SHE'S
BEEN STUDYING ME.
>> YOU GO, NEFERTITI.
>> HEY, SARAH, YOU
ARE, LIKE,
EASIEST FOR THE DAY,
BUT DON'T TELL
ANYONE THAT.
>> THANKS, GUYS.
>> THE
BLONDE--MISS BLONDIE,
WE HAVE TO WATCH OUT
FOR HER BODY, TOO.
HER BODY IS A
LITTLE THICK.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I
CAN PUT MY FOOT UP.
I'M WEARING COMPLETELY
SHEER UNDERWEAR.
I CAN'T POSITION TO
BE COMFORTABLE
WHEN MY SKIRT KEEPS FALLING UP.
>> THIS IS A
FASHION SHOOT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT,
REALISTICALLY SPEAKING,
YOU WOULD DO THIS EVER.
SO YOU WANT TO MAKE
THIS SHOT WORK.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE THINKING OF
HIDING YOURSELF.
CHIN UP ALL THE WAY.
BRITA, SHE REALLY NEEDS
TO LEARN TO RELAX.
>> SHE LOOKS LIKE A
SIDE OF BEEF.
>> THAT'S JUST A BAD ANGLE.
>> YEAH, WHATEVER.
>> READY? GO.
MAKE LOVE TO THE CAMERA.
CHRISTINA WAS A
LOVELY ADDITION TO THE GIRLS.
THE MOMENT I SAW HER,
ACTUALLY,
I THOUGHT, "WOW,
INTERESTING-LOOKING GIRL ."
>> ALL RIGHT,
WE GOT IT.
WELL DONE.
>> WALK IN THOSE
SHOES.
DON'T BE
CREEPY-CRAWLING.
>> LAST TIME I CAME HERE, I HAD
AN ANGER PROBLEM.
BUT NOW MY LIFE HAS CHANGED, SO
I KNOW I HAVE TO PUT
MY BEST FOOT FORWARD.
>> LEAN BACK ON IT.
BOTH LEGS THAT WAY.
THE OTHER WAY.
>> THIS IS A
VERY GHETTO ALIEN.
>> DO THE OTHER PROFILE.
LOOK INTO
THE LIGHT.
INTO THE LIGHT.
THE KEY LIGHT
THAT'S LIGHTING YOU.
TIFFANY HAS SUCH
A SAD STORY,
I FEEL LIKE I'M
SYMPATHIZING WITH HER LIFE
AS OPPOSED TO REALLY
OBJECTIVELY LOOKING AT
WHAT SHE DOES ON
SET.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> I THINK IT WENT PRETTY WELL
FOR IT BEING MY
FIRST TIME.
JAY'S, LIKE,
LAUGHING AT ME
LIKE, "OH, THAT'S
PATHETIC ."
>> THAT ONE'S GOOD.
ALL RIGHT?
SO IT WAS AN INTERESTING FIRST
DAY.
I'M GONNA LEAVE IT
AT THAT.
BUT TYRA GAVE ME A
LITTLE LETTER...
>> (squealing)
>> TYRA MAIL SAYS...
>> (panting)
>> "NOW THAT YOU'VE TAKEN YOUR
VERY FIRST SHOT,
IT'S TIME TO CELEBRATE AT
L .A .'S FINEST SPOT.
SO ENJOY THE NIGHT
AND ALL YOU SEE,
AND TAKE A RIDE
IN LUXURY ."
>> WE GET
OUR TYRA MAIL,
AND IT'S GOT THIS LITTLE CRYPTIC
CODE ABOUT WE GO
TO L.A.'S FINEST SPOT AND LIVING
THE LIFE OF LUXURY.
IT'S SO EXCITING!
♪♪♪
(sirens wailing)
>> GOSH, IT'S,
LIKE, OLD.
WHAT IS ALL THIS?
>> OKAY,
THIS HAS TO BE
A SHORT CUT.
>> WE'RE LOOKING AROUND.
WE'RE, LIKE, WHERE
ARE WE GOING?
>> SHE SAID,
"RIDE INTO LUXURY,"
NOT POVERTY.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> WHERE THE
HELL ARE WE?
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING
IN THE GHETTO?
>> ARE WE IN
THE PROJECTS?
I'M SORRY, YOU KNOW?
I ALREADY LIVE IN
THE PROJECTS.
I DON'T NEED TO GO BACK.
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN THESE
BIKER PEOPLE SHOW UP.
I'M LIKE, WHERE ARE THESE
PEOPLE COMING FROM?
MY HEART KIND OF DROPPED.
THIS IS BAD.
♪♪♪
>> WE TURN AROUND,
AND A FIGURE COMES
INTO THE PICTURE WITH ALL THESE
OTHER PEOPLE.
>> HEY, GIRLS, LOOKING GOOD.
I AM MAGNUS.
WHY DON'T YOU
COME ON IN?
WE ARE ALL, LIKE,
JUST WONDERING WHAT
IS GOING ON.
>> (squealing)
>> YOU'RE AT
SERIOUS CLOTHING.
>> LOOK AT THE CLOTHES!
>> THAT IS AWESOME!
>> YOU GUYS WANT TO COME FORWARD
AND CHECK OUT THIS STUFF?
>> THAT IS SO DOPE!
>> THEY'RE DESIGNERS.
WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT?
>> I LOVE THAT.
>> WELCOME TO
THE SHOWROOM.
WE'RE JUST LOOKING
AT THESE RACKS.
AND STEP
THIS WAY.
WELL, HEY, THE BEST
PART OF THIS
IS ACTUALLY NOT JUST
WHAT GOES ON DOWNSTAIRS.
WELCOME TO YOUR NEW HOME.
>> (squealing)
♪♪♪
>> YES, YES,
YES, YES!
YES, YES, YES, YES, YES!
YES, YES, YES!
>> THE ROOMS ARE KIND OF LIKE
THEMED ON CERTAIN PARTS OF
L .A.
THE WORK-OUT STATION,
MUSCLE BEACH.
SUNSET.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> WE'RE LIVING IN A FASHION
HOUSE, WOW.
>> "THIS IS NOT A SORORITY, IT'S
A MODEL COMPETITION ."
THAT IS SO CUTE.
>> EBONY SAID THAT.
>> OH, OH!
"THIS IS THE WALK THAT WILL
MAKE ME FAMOUS ."
>> CAMILLE.
>> CAMILLE!
>> OH, MY GOD.
EVERYBODY WAS AMAZED HOW
BEAUTIFUL THE HOUSE IS.
IT'S GREAT.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL THING.
>> I WAS EXPECTING THAT WE WERE
GONNA BE STUCK
IN, LIKE, BUNK BEDS,
LIKE CAMP OR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
I HAD NO IDEA.
>> WE CAME TO THE
MODELWOOD ROOM.
>> WE'RE LIKE, ALL RIGHT,
THIS IS MY BED.
I WANT IT.
WE'RE LIVING IN
MODELWOOD, BABY!
>> THE BEL-AIR ROOM IS
KIND OF CHICHI,
KIND OF LIKE A '20s
THEME ALMOST.
THEN THERE'S EAST L.A.
AND THERE'S BEADS,
AND THERE'S, LIKE, CANDLES
EVERYWHERE,
AND IT'S AWESOME.
I LOVE THAT ROOM.
TIFFANY, CAN YOU
BELIEVE THIS, GIRL?
>> I'M GONNA BE NEEDING TO
GO TO SLEEP NOW.
GOOD NIGHT.
>> AT HOME ME AND MY FIANCE
AND MY LITTLE BOY, WE SLEEP
ON THIS TWIN-SIZE MATTRESS,
LIKE THREE MATTRESSES
STACKED TOGETHER.
I'M HAPPY.
I AM SO HAPPY.
>> WE MADE IT, TIFFANY!
OH, I'M LOVING THIS.
>> WOW.
>> HEY, HI,
GIRLS!
>> (squealing)
HOW ARE YOU GUYS DOING?
WELCOME TO L.A.,
YOU GUYS!
>> TYRA'S BEAUTIFUL, I MEAN,
SHE'S BREATHTAKING.
I DON'T WANT TO, LIKE,
TOOT MY OWN HORN,
BUT SHE KIND OF REMINDS ME
OF ME.
>> SO I WANT TO EXPLAIN TO YOU
ALL
WHY YOU'RE IN LOS ANGELES.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE LIKE,
"WAIT, NEW YORK, FASHION CAPITAL
OF THE WORLD.
WAIT, WHAT'S GOING ON?"
I FELT LIKE IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
SHOW YOU GUYS
A DIFFERENT PART OF
THE FASHION WORLD.
THIS IS THE PLACE
THAT I GOT STARTED.
MY MAMA WAS TAKING PICTURES OF
ME, YOU KNOW, IN THE BACKYARD
AND IN THE STREET.
PEOPLE SAY, YOU KNOW,
I COULD BE A MODEL
AND EVERYTHING,
SO I STARTED GOING
TO ALL THESE AGENCIES, AND
THEY'D SAY, "NO, THANK YOU ."
I EXPERIENCED PROBABLY THE
MOST REJECTION IN MY CAREER,
JUST SO MANY
DOORS SLAMMING.
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA EXPERIENCE
A LOT OF REJECTION HERE,
AS WELL.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S ONLY
GONNA BE ONE WINNER,
BUT WE'RE GONNA BE GUIDING
YOU THROUGH THIS WHOLE
ENTIRE PROCESS, SO I WAS LIKE,
"WHY NOT START IN
MY TOWN? "
>> YEAH!
>> YEAH.
>> I MEAN, YOU SEE TYRA,
AND YOU THINK BOOBS
AND LINGERIE.
>> BYE,CHICAS!
>> AND SHE'S GOT A BRAIN.
I MEAN, WHO
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT?
♪♪♪
>> YESTERDAY, THE MAN
MESSED UP MY HAIR TEASING IT,
AND I LOOK LIKE
A FOOL RIGHT NOW.
I'D THINK I WAS A JUNKIE
ON THE STREET
BEGGING
FOR SOME CHANGE.
I MIGHT AS WELL THROW
SOME QUARTERS AT ME.
>> I DON'T THINK
BRANDY'S AS OPEN AS I AM.
YOU CAN SHAVE
MY HEAD BALD.
YOU CAN
DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU GOTTA BE EASY
TO WORK WITH.
>> GIRL, I'M SICK OF
THIS RAGGEDY WEAVE.
♪♪♪
>> AAH!
>> HELLO.
>> HEY!
>> WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> (squealing)
>> WHEN I SAW
J. AGAIN,
OH, I LOVE HIM.
HE'S LIKE ONE
OF THE GIRLS.
>> PRACTICE MAKES
PERFECT.
WHEN YOU GUYS
GET FINISHED,
WHAT WE NEED TO DO
IS REALLY
JUST KIND OF DO
WEIGHTS AND MEASURES
SEE WHO IS TONED AND
WHO'S CONSIDERED FAT
AND WHO THINKS
SHE'S FAT.
>> I'M FAT.
>> MISS J. IS HERE TO TAKE OUR
MEASUREMENTS.
>> OH, SHOOT!
I'M GOING THROUGH AN INSECURE
PHASE,
BECAUSE I'VE GAINED WEIGHT
RECENTLY.
>> IT JIGGLES A BIT.
>> MISS KAHLEN,
STEP UP.
YOU ARE 114 POUNDS,
BABY.
>> WHAT?
>> WOW, SHE'S
LITTLER THAN ME!
>> YOU'RE ALMOST SHAPED LIKE A
BOY MINUS THE BREASTS.
>> (laughs)
>> THANKS.
>> WHEW, CHILD,
CHILD!
SHE HAS A FUTURE
BEHIND HER.
YES, SHE DOES.
>> (laughs)
>> OOH, SORRY.
YOU ARE 118 POUNDS.
122.
123.
124.
116.
123.
>> I'M NOT
ONE OF THE SKINNY GIRLS.
I'M NERVOUS, YEAH.
YOU KNOW, FINE, I'M NERVOUS.
>> NEXT!
116.
BRITA.
>> I GAINED 10 POUNDS.
>> OOH.
>> I'VE BEEN SICK.
>> BABY,
NORMALLY WHEN
YOU'RE SICK,
YOU LOSE WEIGHT.
>> I'M THE OPPOSITE.
>> MM-HMM.
138.
>> TRUST ME,
AT THE END
OF THIS,
I'LL LOSE IT.
>> SHE IS JUST
A LITTLE BIT BIGGER
THAN THE REST OF US.
I HOPE BEING WEIGHED IN TODAY
ISN'T MAKING HER FEEL
THAT SELF-CONSCIOUS,
'CAUSE SHE'S BEAUTIFUL.
♪♪♪
>> AAH!
>> YOU GOT IT.
>> YOU SNAGGED IT,
LITTLE GIRL.
>> TYRA MAIL.
>> IT SAYS, "WHO WILL
GET CUT?
FIND OUT TOMORROW.
BE READY AT 9 A.M."
>> SOMEBODY IS
GETTING CUT,
AND IT WOULD BE,
LIKE, HORRIFIC
FOR ANYONE THAT MADE IT
THIS FAR
TO GET CUT SO EARLY.
>> THIS IS REALLY
HARD FOR ME,
REALLY HARD.
>> I DON'T WANT TO SEE PEOPLE
GO, BUT, I MEAN...
>> I KNOW.
THERE'S ONLY GONNA BE
ONE PERSON THAT WINS.
>> YEAH, IT
IS A COMPETITION.
>> I KNOW THAT,
BUT, LIKE, AH!
>> THERE'S SO MUCH
GOING THROUGH
MY HEAD RIGHT NOW,
THAT IT'S GONNA BE
ROUGH TOMORROW.
♪♪♪
>> KAHLEN, BABY, IT'S TIME
TO WAKE UP.
>> OKAY.
>> NO MORE SLEEPING,
BABY.
>> WE GOT A TYRA MAIL THAT
SAYS, "WHO WILL BE CUT? "
>> I REALLY HONESTLY
DON'T KNOW WHO'S
GONNA GO HOME.
IT'S GONNA BE DEFINITELY
A SURPRISE.
>> IT'S 9:15!
WE NEED TO
LEAVE RIGHT NOW.
>> SOMEBODY HAS
TO GET CUT.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S SO MUCH SPECULATION,
I CAN'T EVEN HANDLE IT.
>> HELLO!
>> HI!
>> LADIES, SO I KNOW YOU
GOT THE TYRA MAIL.
WHO'S GONNA GET CUT?
WHERE ARE WE
TODAY?
>> THE SALON.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> A MAKEOVER!
>> (squealing)
>> YOU GUYS ARE
AT PRIVE SALON,
AND WE HAVE
SOME AMAZING FOLKS.
COME ON OUT HERE.
FIRST WE HAVE GUY.
GUY'S GONNA BE
TOTALLY IN CHARGE
OF YOUR LOOKS TODAY.
MISS CARMEN IS
FROM THE PAINT SHOP,
GONNA BE HOOKING UP
YOU NAILS TODAY.
AND THEN WE HAVE MOKOKO.
SO SHE'S GONNA BE DOING YOUR
MAKEOVERS FOR YOUR FACES
FOR OUR SEXY
PHOTO SHOOT TODAY.
>> WHOO, YES!
>> SARAH, WE'RE
GONNA GIVE YOU
A VERY PETER PAN--
INSPIRED HAIRCUT.
MICHELLE, WE THINK THAT YOU
HAVE A VERY ETHEREAL LOOK,
SO WE'RE GONNA MAKE
YOU ICE BLONDE, GIRL.
>> (squealing)
>> NOELLE. WE'RE GONNA
BLOW YOU OUT, GIRL,
AND MAKE YOU FIERCE.
TATIANA, WE'LL GONNA DARKEN
YOU AND MAKE YOU VERY RICH,
A LA PAULINA PORIZKOVA.
TIFFANY, YOU GOT A BIG-ASS CRAZY
PERSONALITY THAT CAN HANDLE HAIR
ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO HERE.
>> (squealing)
>> I BELIEVE THAT,
I BELIEVE THAT!
>> KAHLEN, WE'RE GONNA GIVE
YOU A HAIR WEAVE, VERY BLUNT,
A LA CARMEN KASS.
BRITTANY, WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO
TAKE YOU
A LITTLE BIT SHORTER,
MAKE THAT BANG VERY
HEAVY AND VERY OOMPH.
CHRISTINA, WE THINK THAT YOU
HAVE A FACE LIKE THE GIRLS
ON THE COVER
OF "VOGUE"
RIGHT NOW, SO WE WANT
TO MAKE YOU LIKE
THOSE HOT GIRLS
OF THE MOMENT--
DEEPER, DARKER,
FULLER HAIR.
REBECCA, WE WANT
TO EDGE YOU OUT,
THICK AND LONG
AND LUSCIOUS.
>> (squeals)
>> BRITA. YOU'RE
GONNA GET THESE LITTLE
TIGHT LITTLE WAVES
LIKE A PRINCESS BRIDE.
>> YES, REALLY!
>> LLUVY,
LLUVY REMINDS ME
OF A NEW TYPE
OF SHELLEY DUVALL,
SO WE'RE GONNA
MAKE YOUR HAIR RED.
>> RED?
OH, MY GOD!
>> YES, KEENYAH, YOU'RE GONNA
GET AN OLD KIND OF
VIDAL SASSOON-INSPIRED
ASYMMETRICAL BANG.
NAIMA, WE ARE GONNA MAKE
YOU HONEY BLONDE, GIRL.
>> MISS BRANDY.
>> MISS BRANDY,
WE HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT YOU,
AND WE DECIDED, GIRL,
THAT YOU ARE FIERCE.
>> FIERCE!
>> AND WE AIN'T
DOING NOTHING TO YOU!
>> NADA.
>> YOU ARE...
>> WHEN WE SHE TOLD ME
I WAS GONNA KEEP THE AFRO,
I'M PISSED OFF.
I WAS JUST LIKE, "WHY?
" BECAUSE I WANTED
A DRASTIC
CHANGE SO BAD.
>> ALL RIGHTY,
LET'S GO!
>> WHOO!
>> YEAH, I'M JUST GONNA FIND OUT
IF BLONDES HAVE MORE FUN.
>> EXACTLY.
>> WERE YOU
EVER BLONDE?
>> HEY!
>> I'M GONNA NEED
TO MOVE.
I'M SORRY.
Y'ALL HURTING MY
FEELINGS RIGHT NOW.
>> YOUR FEELINGS
ARE BEING HURT?
>> YES!
'CAUSE THEY'RE ALL,
"WE'RE GONNA GET A
NEW LOOK ."
I'M SORRY.
I'M NOT GETTING
A NEW LOOK.
>> WE WERE HAVING ISSUES IN
THE BEGINNING FOR BRANDY
ABOUT HER HAIR.
>> DO YOU FEEL
THE DREADS UP IN THERE?
>> IT IS FULL,
YES.
>> BRANDY, I'M GONNA HAVE TO
TAKE THIS OFF, PRECIOUS.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU
REALLY, REALLY SHORT,
BUT REALLY
BRIGHT STILL.
>> BECAUSE THIS IS
COMING OFF.
I'M VERY HAPPY ABOUT
THE CHANGE OR WHATEVER,
BECAUSE I DO NOT WANT
TO KEEP THIS AFRO.
>> SO ARE THEY
CUTTING HER?
>> YES.
>> FINALLY.
SHE WAS SO CRANKY
AT FIRST.
>> JUST DO ME GOOD,
JUST DO ME GOOD.
THAT'S ALL I ASK.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
YOU'VE EVER BEEN BLONDE?
>> YES, EVER.
>> EVER. A VIRGIN.
OH, I LOVE
THIS.
>> SO I'M GETTING MY
FIRST OFFICIAL WEAVE
WITH LONG EXTENSIONS.
IT FEELS LIKE
EVERYTHING I WEAR,
BUT IT BETTER
BE BEAUTIFUL.
STAND RIGHT HERE,
YEAH,
AND IT'S GONNA
BE A SHOT.
IT'S GONNA BE
A TOPLESS SHOT
WHERE YOU SHOW THE BREAST.
>> I AM A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE BEING NAKED.
I KNEW THAT SOMEWHERE
WITHIN THIS COMPETITION,
THERE WAS GOING TO BE
A TOPLESS SOMETHING.
I JUST WASN'T
EXPECTING IT TO BE SO SOON.
>> IT'S VERY HEALTHY.
>> THEY MADE MY
HAIR DARKER.
I REALLY LIKE IT.
I THINK I DID
A GREAT JOB
IN THE PHOTO SHOOT.
I FEEL VERY CONFIDENT.
>> I DEFINITELY LIKE
THE DARKNESS AND THE RICHNESS
OF MY HAIR, AND
IT'S MORE SEXY,
IT'S MORE PLAYFUL,
SO I DEFINITELY
LIKE IT A LOT.
>> I'M ACTUALLY REALLY HAPPY
THAT THEY DECIDED NOT TO DO
A CRAZY MAKEOVER
ON ME.
I'VE HAD MAKEOVERS IN THE PAST.
I ALWAYS COME BACK TO
THIS LOOK,
AND THIS IS WHAT
WORKS FOR ME.
>> I HAVE HAD A
SEWN-IN WEAVE BEFORE,
BUT THIS TIME
I'M SITTING HERE
FOR MUCH LONGER.
THE BLOOD IS ALL RUSHING TO
THE SPOTS WHERE SHE'S BRAIDING.
I'M JUST TAKING IT
LIKE A PRO,
I THINK.
>> OKAY.
>> OH, GOD!
>> I'M BALD-HEADED
AGAIN.
>> I THINK YOU
STILL LOOK SEXY.
I'M SORRY.
I'M GOING STRAIGHT TO THE
NEXT PHOTO SHOOT.
>> BUT YOU STILL HAVE
SOMETHING TO WORK WITH.
>> MY MAKEOVER IS VERY FUNKY,
AND IT'S VERY EDGY,
SO I FEEL LIKE IT
DEFINITELY SHOWS
A DIFFERENT SIDE TO ME
THAT I REALLY ENJOY.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S, LIKE, ALL OVER.
WHOO!
THEY WARNED ME BEFORE THAT
IT WAS GONNA HURT
AND EVERYTHING,
BUT OOH,
IT WAS VICIOUS.
>> DOES IT BURN?
>> NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
IT STILL BURNS.
OOH!
>> MICHELLE, SHE'S FEELING
THE PAIN OF BEING
ALL BLEACHED BLONDE.
IS IT EXCRUCIATING.
>> MICHELLE'S SO...
I DON'T KNOW THE WORD, BUT SHE
JUST DON'T COMPLAIN.
SHE WON'T COMPLAIN,
AND I LOVE THAT ABOUT HER.
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> I LOVE IT.
OH, MY GOD,
THIS GUY'S
A MAGICIAN.
>> YOU'RE THE
HOTTEST PETER PAN
I'VE EVER SEEN.
>> I THINK I LOOK FANTASTIC,
AND I LOVE THE CUT.
I LOVE THE COLOR.
I LOVE THE MAKEUP.
I LOVE IT ALL.
I FEEL LIKE A SUPERMODEL.
>> THIS IS GONNA
LOOK SO DOPE.
I LIKE IT.
>> I WOULD HAVE
PROBABLY CHOSEN
A REALLY, REALLY
LIGHT COLOR
OR A REALLY,
REALLY DARK COLOR,
BUT THIS SPOT IN
BETWEEN IS PERFECT.
I LOVE IT.
>> UP.
SHAKE IT OUT.
I'VE LOOKED EXACTLY
THE SAME
MY ENTIRE LIFE.
>> GENIUS, MAJOR!
>> I JUST FEEL LIKE
A COMPLETELY NEW PERSON.
I LOVE IT.
PUT ME IN A
TIME CAPSULE.
I'LL KEEP
THIS FOREVER.
>> NOW THAT'S BLONDE.
>> THEY PUT ME THROUGH HELL,
BUT, I MEAN, I'M LOVING IT NOW.
MY HAIR IS GONNA CHANGE
ME FOR THE BETTER,
BECAUSE I'M FEELING
MORE CONFIDENT.
I THINK BLONDES DO HAVE
MORE FUN.
>> WE WANT IT TIGHT,
VERY ASYMMETRICAL,
LIKE OLD VIDAL SASSOON.
IF WE CAN KEEP IT
VERY, VERY BLUNT.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS GONNA
BE SO BLUNT OF A CUT.
IT KIND OF CRUSHED ME.
I MEAN, I HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO DO WHAT YOU SAY.
>> BUT IT'S NOT WHAT
I WANT TO DO.
THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT BOTH J.,
MYSELF AND TYRA SAT
DOWN AND TALKED ABOUT.
WE CAN GET TYRA ON THE PHONE IF
YOU WANT TO TALK TO HER
ABOUT IT.
>> NO, I'M FINE WITH IT.
I'M REALLY FINE WITH IT.
>> BUT YOU'RE NOT FINE
WITH IT,
BECAUSE YOU QUESTIONED
THE HAIRDRESSERS.
YOU QUESTIONED ME.
THAT'S NOT COOL.
>> I LOVE MY NEW MAKEOVER.
>> SEDUCTION, SEDUCTION.
>> MY MAKEUP IS A LOT
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT I'M USED TO.
>> I JUST GOT MY
MAKEOVER, AND I'M HOT.
HELLO!
MAJOR BANG POWER.
LOVE IT!
>> YOU'D BETTER
DO-RAG, RAP!
>> I'M SO EXCITED.
I HAVE A NEW, TOTALLY
DIFFERENT LOOK THAT
I WOULD NEVER
HAVE THOUGHT OF.
I'M SO HAPPY.
MISS J. DECIDED TO GIVE
MY BABY A MAKEOVER.
I MEAN, THIS IS A GUY,
BUT HE LOOKS CUTE.
>> I HAD TO GET MY MAKEUP DONE
FOR THE PHOTO SHOOT,
BUT THE EYEBROWS
ARE BLACK,
AND THAT'S NOT
GONNA MATCH.
HOW AM I GONNA GO BACK
TO MY BOYFRIEND?
HE'S NOT GONNA WANT
ME NO MORE.
WHOO, WHOA!
>> BRANDY, YOUR ATTITUDE
IS JUST RIDICULOUS.
>> I'M SORRY.
I DON'T CARE WHO DON'T
LIKE ME NO MORE,
BUT I CAN'T
SEE MY EYEBROWS.
>> MISS BRANDY, HER ATTITUDE
JUST PISSED ME OFF.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S LIKE YOU
AND KEENYAH'S GOT SOMETHING
GOING ON WITH HER HAIR.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON THERE,
AND IT'S LIKE, I'M GETTING
FRUSTRATED NOW.
I'M REACHING A POINT WHERE,
CHILD, HERE, TALK TO J.
>> WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
>> NO PROBLEM WITH ME.
>> IS IT WITH YOU?
>> THIS LOOKS SO GOOD, I CAN'T
BELIEVE IT.
>> I TOLD YOU.
>> I REALLY CAN'T BELIEVE
IT, LIKE...
>> TODAY THE DRAMA WAS SO
NOT INTENDED.
I'M NOT THE TYPE OF PERSON THAT
EVER, EVER COMPLAINS.
I'M SO STUPID,
SO, SO STUPID.
I AM IN LOVE WITH
THIS HAIRSTYLE.
IT'S GORGEOUS.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT ABOUT HAVING
A SHORT HAIRSTYLE
TO MAKE MY FACE
AND MY STRUCTURE
STAND OUT SO MUCH.
>> HEY, HEY, EVERYBODY!
>> HI!
>> I WANT EVERYBODY TO
COME OVER HERE.
PART OF BEING A TOP MODEL
IS ABOUT ACCEPTING CHANGE,
ABOUT BEING
A BLANK PALETTE.
I HAVE THE TOP PEOPLE
IN THE INDUSTRY HERE
THAT HAVE MOLDED
AND SHAPED MY CAREER,
AND I WANT TO COMMEND 12
OF YOU FOR BEING OPEN,
BUT THERE ARE TWO OF YOU,
AND YOU KNOW WHO YOU ARE,
THAT PISSED ME OFF.
AND NEXT TIME I SEE YOU
GUYS WILL BE AT JUDGING,
AND THIS WILL
DEFINITELY EFFECT THAT.
SO I'LL SEE YOU
GUYS AT JUDGING.
>> OH, THERE'S TYRA MAIL!
>> TYRA MAIL.
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL
MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 13 OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES
OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL
BE ELIMINATED ."
>> I THINK IT'S GONNA COME
DOWN TO BRANDY AND I,
AND THEY'RE GONNA MAKE A
CUT OUT OF US TWO.
>> WE'LL NEED A
MIRACLE RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE I DO NOT WANT
TO GET ELIMINATED.
>> YOU NEED TO
CHANGE YOUR ATTITUDE,
'CAUSE YOUR
ATTITUDE STINKS.
YOU'VE GOTTA LOSE
THE ANGER, BABY.
♪♪♪
>> HI, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> WELCOME TO YOUR FIRST
JUDGING EXPERIENCE.
YOU GUYS LOOK AMAZING,
BUT SOMEONE HAS
TO GO HOME TONIGHT.
WE HAVE SOME
AMAZING PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL MODEL
MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN
"ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
A $100, 000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL
COSMETICS.
>> OH!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> NOW IT'S TIME TO INTRODUCE
OUR PANEL OF JUDGES.
FIRST WE HAVE
JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S FIRST
SUPERMODELS.
>> HELLO.
>> NIGEL BARKER, A
WORLD-RENOWNED
AND NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
>> HI, GIRLS.
>> NOLE MARIN, A PROMINENT
EDITOR AND STYLIST.
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR YOUR
INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
YOU HAD A PHOTO
SHOOT WHERE YOU
WERE ALIENS ON
THE LOOSE,
AND, NAIMA,
YOU'RE FIRST.
THE FIRST PICTURE OF THIS WHOLE
EXPERIENCE IS NAIMA,
AND HERE IT IS.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> I LIKE THE
SLINKINESS.
>> YOUR FIRST PHOTOGRAPH,
YOU REALLY PULLED IT OFF.
>> NOELLE,
FIRST OFF, NOELLE,
YOU HAD THAT
BEAUTIFUL BLOWOUT.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I WANTED TO SEE WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE CURLY.
>> BIG MISTAKE.
>> WHY'D YOU MESS WITH A GOOD
THING?
>> HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
WHAT'S THIS?
>> THERE YOU ARE.
>> YOU MIGHT BE MAKING UP FOR
THAT CURLY HAIR YOU GOT
RIGHT NOW.
>> CHRISTINA.
HERE IT IS.
I THINK IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> I DO, TOO.
LOOK AT THAT,
BEAUTIFUL EYES.
>> MICHELLE.
WELL, ONE THING I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU ON
IS YOUR MAKEOVER.
I HEARD THAT
IT WAS BURNING,
BUT YOU WERE
VERY MODELESQUE
AND TOOK IT.
THERE'S A
FAMOUS HAIRDRESSER
BY THE NAME OF ORBE,
AND I REMEMBER HAVING
NEW HAIR EXTENSIONS.
IT'S PAINFUL,
AND HE'S PULLING IT
AND PULLING
IT AND PULLING IT
AND TWISTING IT INTO THESE
PRINCESS LEIA BUNS.
AND I WANTED TO
CRY SO BAD.
>> BOO HOO!
>> IT MADE ME
A LITTLE TEARY,
YOU KNOW?
BUT I KIND OF HID
IT FROM HIM AND SUCKED UP
AND GOT AN AMAZING
PICTURE.
AND THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
IT'S ABOUT PUSHING THROUGH THE
PAIN AND THE DISCOMFORT
AS A MODEL,
SO BRAVO.
AND HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOU LOOK FABULOUS WITH
THE BODY, BUT THE FACE,
YOU DIDN'T NAIL IT FOR ME ON
THAT ONE.
>> TATIANA.
I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU, YOU, OUT
OF ALL THE GIRLS,
HAVE MORE MOVES THAN ANYBODY
ELSE.
>> A LOT OF GIRLS DIDN'T...
THEY WERE LIKE, "OH, I DIDN'T
KNOW I COULD DO THIS ."
>> BRITA.
>> WHAT KIND OF A
NAME IS FRITA?
>> BRITA.
>> OH, BRITA.
>> OKAY, BRITA, HERE'S
YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> THAT'S NOT
A GOOD SHOT, HONEY.
YOU LOOK WORRIED.
YOU LOOK OLD.
>> I DON'T SEE WHAT
I SEE IN FRONT OF ME.
THIS LOOKS HOT.
THIS IS NOT EVEN A ONE.
>> SARAH.
WHOA!
>> THIS IS A HOT SHOT.
>> IT WAS FUN
TO SHOOT YOU.
>> KAHLEN.
>> YOU KNOW
WHAT?
YOU WERE
UNBELIEVABLE UP THERE,
AND YOU'RE NOT
ROCKING MY WORLD
IN FRONT OF ME RIGHT
NOW.
>> VERY PARTRIDGE FAMILY.
>> BRITTANY.
>> WOW, HONEY, YOU WERE LIKE
LIKE A PANTHER CRAWLING UP
THAT POLICE CAR.
>> THE ONLY ISSUE THAT WE HAD IS
YOU HAD AN EASY TENDENCY TO
MAKE THE PICTURE
LOOK TOO SEXY.
JUST TRY AND BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE ELEGANT.
>> KEENYAH.
THAT'S... IS THAT
THE HAIRSTYLE
THAT THEY DID?
'CAUSE I WAS NOT THERE
AT THE END.
>> NOT, IT WASN'T.
I ACTUALLY PUT SOME OIL IN IT,
AND IT GOT REALLY STRINGY.
>> WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
I DON'T WANT TO
HEAR THAT.
>> YOU WERE ONE OF THE GIRLS
THAT I WAS ADDRESSING,
FEELING LIKE YOU KNEW BETTER
THAN ME AND J. AND JAY.
>> I REGRET THAT.
I FEEL LIKE IT WAS THE BIGGEST
MISTAKE
I'VE MADE IN
MY LIFE.
>> OH!
>> HERE IS YOUR
BEST SHOT.
THIS IS GORGEOUS.
>> YES!
>> THE LESSON THAT YOU NEED TO
LEARN IS THAT
IF I SAID THAT I WANTED YOUR
MAKEOVER TO BE THIS HAIR,
THAT YOU NEED TO
SIT THERE
AND SAY, "OH,
GOD, IT'S FIERCE!
YEAH, I LOVE IT!"
>> LLUVY.
HERE IS YOUR BEST
SHOT AS AN ALIEN.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE
SLEEPY ALIEN.
>> YOU COULD HAVE
BEEN FIERCE,
AND YOU'RE NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO A GROWL.
>> TIFFANY.
>> THE HAIR
TOTALLY HELPED YOU
LOOK COMPLETELY
MODELESQUE.
>> GORGEOUS.
>> IT IS GORGEOUS, BUT
I NOTICED THAT WE HAD
TO GET YOU INTO
THAT PROFILE.
BECAUSE WHEN
YOU LOOKED STRAIGHT AT US,
YOU OFTEN LOOKED
BEWILDERED,
BUT YOU DID A GOOD JOB.
>> LAST SEASON OF "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL, "
YOU DIDN'T MAKE IT,
AND ONE THING THAT
YOU SAID WAS...
>> IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A BIG
CHANGE FROM HUSTLING
TO BEING A
GLAMOUR GIRL, ANYWAY.
>> AND NOW YOU
ARE A GLAMOUR GIRL,
AND I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT YOU FEEL
WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THAT PICTURE.
>> IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
I JUST...
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> IT'S REALLY HARD ALWAYS
HAVING TO BE TOUGH,
YOU KNOW, WHEN PEOPLE SEE
ME ON THE STREET.
IT'S ALWAYS THAT GIRL
THAT FIGHTS OR THAT TOUGH GIRL.
AND WHEN I LOOK, YOU KNOW,
I CAN BE BEAUTIFUL,
AND IT FEELS GREAT.
IT MAKES ME
FEEL GOOD.
>> I THINK ADVERSITY AND
NEGATIVE THINGS ACTUALLY
MAKE US BETTER ARTISTS,
BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU CAN
PULL FROM.
THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> REBECCA.
>> HOT.
>> HOT, VERY HOT.
>> GIRL, YOU LOOK LONG,
LEAN
AND
TOTALLY FASHION FORWARD.
>> WORK IT, GIRL!
I'M DOWN WITH IT.
>> LAST BUT
NOT LEAST, BRANDY.
>> BRANDY, SO YOU
ARE WORKING THIS NEW LOOK,
BUT I KNOW IT WAS
A STRUGGLE GETTING THERE.
>> WHEN WERE
LIKE, "WELL,
WE'RE GONNA CUT
IT ALL OFF, "
I WAS LIKE... IT
WAS LIKE A RELEASE,
SO I WAS LIKE,
"OKAY ."
>> OH, YOU'RE JUST LEAVING OFF
THE OTHER PART JUST LIKE
A LITTLE GIRL IN
FRONT OF HER MAMA.
>> WAIT,
WAIT, WAIT, WHAT?
>> YOU WERE VERY NEGATIVE ABOUT
EYEBROWS BEING BLEACHED,
SAYING THAT
YOU LOOKED CRAZY.
>> BUT I NEVER ONCE SAID, "I
DON'T LIKE IT ."
>> YOU'RE THE ONLY GIRL WHO
ACTUALLY HAD THE AUDACITY,
WHEN SHE ARRIVED
ON MY SET,
AND I SAID,
"HOW ARE YOU? "
YOU SAID....
>> I WAS WAITING SO LONG.
I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
I'M IN THE
MIDDLE OF SLEEPINESS.
>> AND I WAS LIKE,
"HEY ."
>> YOU CAN'T SAY THAT TO A
DIRECTOR OR A PHOTOGRAPHER!
>> IT MAKES ME
VERY CONFUSED.
FIRST OF ALL, I WANT
TO GO TO YOUR SHOT.
LET'S GO TO YOUR
PICTURE FIRST.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
PICTURE.
>> AND YOU HAD LOTS
OF GOOD PICTURES,
BUT IT WASN'T FUN
TO HAVE YOU AROUND.
>> I WANT TO TAKE YOU BACK
TO THE SEMIFINALS
WHEN I CALLED
YOUR NAME.
BRANDY.
YOU HAD ONE OF THE BIGGEST
RESPONSES.
>> (sobbing)
>> WHERE IS
THAT THANKFUL PERSON?
ALL WE'VE EXPERIENCED IS BRANDY
BEAUTIFUL ON THE OUTSIDE.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE
JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN WE CALL YOU BACK, WE
WILL DETERMINE
WHO'S GOING HOME.
>> BRITTANY.
>> SHE STAYS.
>> IS IT 'CAUSE SHE LOOKS LIKE
YOU, JANICE?
>> YOU KNOW, YOU REALLY NEED
LASIK, HONEY.
I DON'T HAVE HANDS THE
SIZE OF BASEBALL MITTS HERE.
>> (laughs)
TIFFANY.
TIFFANY JUMPED IN AND
OUT OF THAT CAR
AND LOOKED LIKE SHE'D SEEN THOSE
RED LIGHTS BEFORE,
BUT, HONEY, YOU GOT THE SHOT.
>> SARAH.
>> HER FACE IS SO STRONG THAT
IT COULD CARRY HER VERY FAR.
>> NAIMA.
>> NAIMA IS EXQUISITE.
>> SHE HAS THIS PERSONAL STYLE
ABOUT HER WHICH I NOTICED
FROM THE GET-GO.
>> LLUVY.
>> S.U.V.
>> (laughing)
>> THAT'S HER NEW NAME.
I HAVE DEEMED IT.
I THINK S.U.V. IS SO CUTE,
BUT IN THE PHOTOGRAPH
SHE LOOKS LIKE A MAN.
>> KEENYAH.
>> TONIGHT HER HAIRDO LOOKED
LIKE A HELMET ON THE SIDE
OF HER HEAD.
>> AS MUCH AS SHE TRIED TO CLEAN
UP THAT ATTITUDE
AND PRETEND LIKE IT WASN'T AS
BAD AS IT WAS...
>> I SAW RIGHT THROUGH IT.
>> OH, SHE WAS, OH, BEYOND.
MISS DIVA.
CHRISTINA.
>> I'M IN LOVE
WITH THIS GIRL.
>> THE PROBLEM IS THAT SHE HAS
ALMOST ZERO SEX APPEAL.
>> BRANDY.
>> SHE JUST, YOU KNOW...
SHE'S JUST GIVING TOO
MUCH ATTITUDE.
I'M SORRY.
>> THERE IS DEFINITELY
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
A GREAT PICTURE OF
THIS GIRL,
BUT WHO WANTS HER AROUND?
>> BRITA.
>> SHE'S A VERY SEXY GIRL IN
PERSON, MY GOD!
PHOTOGRAPH, EH.
>> BRITA IS
25 YEARS OLD,
AND SHE'S HOLDING WAY
TOO MUCH WEIGHT.
AND ON TOP OF THAT, SHE WAS A
VERY STIFF MODEL.
>> KAHLEN.
>> SHE WORKED THIS IMAGE, BUT
WHEN I SAW HER
IN PERSON TONIGHT, SHE REALLY
JUST LOOKED DRAB.
>> REBECCA.
>> I THINK REBECCA'S GREAT.
>> THIS GIRL MOVES LIKE
THE GIRLS THAT ARE WORKING
IN MAGAZINES ALREADY.
>> TATIANA.
>> HER FACE IS ALMOST
A LITTLE PUGSLEY,
NOSE AND MOUTH AND EYES
IS ALL TOUCHING EACH OTHER.
>> NOELLE.
>> SHE'S A REALLY
PRETTY GIRL.
I DON'T LIKE THAT SHE CHANGED
HER HAIR ONCE AGAIN.
IF SHE CAN'T BRING
IT HOME,
BYE-BYE.
>> MICHELLE.
>> THE THING ABOUT HER IS THAT
SHE'S SO BIG,
SHE BORDERLINES
LOOKING LIKE
SOMEONE IN DRAG.
>> SHE DEFINITELY
HAS POTENTIAL,
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
MICHELLE/MICHAEL CONTINUE.
>> I HAVE 14 ABSOLUTELY
BEAUTIFUL WOMEN
STANDING IN FRONT
OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
13 PICTURES
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PICTURES REPRESENT THE
13 OF YOU THAT ARE STILL
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL--
TIFFANY.
CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE
RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
NAIMA.
REBECCA.
KAHLEN.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL--
CHRISTINA.
MICHELLE.
>> YES!
>> NOELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
>> SARAH.
TATIANA.
BRITTANY.
>> THERE'S FOUR GIRLS LEFT,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
THREE PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
>> LLUVY.
>> KEENYAH.
SOMEBODY LEARNED A BIG LESSON
THIS WEEK, DIDN'T THEY?
>> HUGE.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WILL BRITA AND
BRANDY PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS ONE
PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT
WILL STILL BE IN THE
RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO YOUR LOFT, PACK YOUR
BELONGINGS AND LEAVE.
BRITA, YOU WALKED IN HERE,
AND ALL THE JUDGES SAID,
WOW, WHAT AN AMAZINGLY
BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT THEN THE JUDGES
EVALUATE YOUR PHOTO, AND SOME OF
THEM DON'T WANT
TO SEE YOU ANYMORE.
BRANDY, YOU'RE
STANDING THERE
HIGH FASHION
AND EDGY,
ALL THE POTENTIAL
IN THE WORLD,
BUT YOUR ATTITUDE ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT JUDGES WANT
TO BE AROUND.
A LOT OF THESE JUDGES
BEHIND ME
DON'T WANT TO
SEE YOU EITHER.
>> BUT SOME OF THEM DO.
BRANDY, CONGRATULATIONS.
>> OH!
THANK YOU SO MUCH, TYRA!
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GONNA
TRY TO WORK ON?
>> MY ATTITUDE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BEING BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, BRITA.
>> THANKS, GUYS.
I'M JUST PISSED
OFF RIGHT NOW.
I'M ACTUALLY REGRETTING THIS
EXPERIENCE A LITTLE BIT.
THE FIRST GIRL
KICKED OFF,
PICTURES WERE HORRIBLE.
UGH!
GOD, THIS SUCKS.
I WAS HOPING THAT THIS WOULD BE
THE NEXT BIGGER, BETTER THING
FOR ME,
AND I BLEW IT.
>> STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
>> COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
MODEL, "
AS THE GIRLS
STRUT THEIR STUFF
FOR MISS J.,
HE DOESN'T HAVE MUCH
TO CHEER ABOUT.
AND WHEN MICHELLE
BEGINS TO FEEL THE PRESSURE,
HER DEEPEST SECRET IS REVEALED.
>> AND I'M JUST RELUCTANT TO,
LIKE, TELL EVERYONE,
BECAUSE HOW
PEOPLE WOULD REACT.
>> ALL LEADING UP TO THE
MOST SHOCKING JUDGING EVER.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> I'M CALLING 911.